hello everyone welcome to la blockchain
summit
i am incredibly excited to have chairman
tarbert here with me
uh thank you so much for joining and
doing this my pleasure it's great to be
here at
la blockchain absolutely you've got a
very kind of um
interesting and storied career across
finance and business
maybe just let's start with your
background and kind of how you get to
the chairmanship
of the cftc and then if you can also
mention a little bit about just the role
the cftc plays in the financial markets
uh for those that don't know that yeah
well thank you and of course it's great
to be here with you
pop i mean you are a leader in this
field
many of us of the cftc listen to your
podcast so
it's it's an incredible pleasure for me
to be here so how did i end up here it's
a great question
it was somewhat of a circuitous route so
like most people in washington
my background is a mixture of law and
public service
and also a deep finance background
and so i i've served in a variety of
different functions i've actually served
in all three branches of the us
government
was a clerk at the federal judiciary
both at the
u.s court of appeals in the u.s supreme
court i had worked in the white house
and a couple of administrations ago
i had worked on the senate banking
committee during the dodd-frank act
discussions
and then ultimately found myself a
couple of years ago
as assistant secretary of the treasury
with the international portfolio but
focusing on
uh regulation but also technology
and then i was invited uh and nominated
ultimately confirmed by the senate to be
cftc
chairman so it is a great pleasure
because what i tell
many people is that the cftc is the most
important regulator most americans have
never heard of
but we regulate the derivatives markets
but the derivatives markets are so
important
because they touch so many other
underlying markets
and in fact 10 years ago we would be
very odd to have the derivatives
regulator talking to
folks in la and silicon valley and
elsewhere but it's because the
definition of commodity includes so many
things
and now bitcoin ether some of the
cryptocurrencies
are under the purview of the cftc but so
is gold
so is wheat so is corn so are financial
contracts
interest rates so there's so many things
that the derivatives markets track
they basically enable the us economy but
quite frankly the foreign economy as a
whole
to work because they're a place where
people can lay off risk
and also get price discovery so many of
the things
even cattle for example sometimes the
price of cattle
is actually set in the derivatives
markets and people say well the third
the futures contract on cattle says it
should be x amount per head
and therefore this is what it the price
should be in the real market and so
that's the
critical role that the derivatives
markets play
yeah it really is incredible just kind
of the the purview that you guys have
and also i think
the cftc for the last number of years
has been very um
you know forward thinking in terms of
how they've thought about uh the role of
cryptocurrency
and digital assets uh not only today but
also kind of where we're going
uh which i think has served a a very big
beneficiary you know being to the
community let's talk a little bit about
central bank digital currencies uh you
know
i think everyone realizes that the
united states wants to be a technology
leader wants to be
a leader in the global financial system
and one of these topics obviously is
this central bank digital currency that
we're seeing china and other places
uh start to either play around with the
idea and kind of research it or actually
move towards implementation
maybe from your seat you can give us a
sense of just is a central bank digital
currency going to be the standard for
nation states around the world
is the u.s going to play a part in that
and kind of how you see that developing
here in the united states
uh and then also globally yeah it's a
great question
and really where i stand is i want to
see the united states
lead in blockchain technology for me
it's not necessarily something that the
government needs to be
and and be involved with directly but
there could be benefits to that as well
but i really want to see the united
states continue to support
innovation in this space because i do
see other countries coming in
and starting to potentially take the
lead and i think it's really important
that a debt
a democracy such as ours uh continues to
be on the forefront of this for the
future of the global financial system
for central bank currencies in
particular i think ultimately i'm going
to obviously
defer to my fellow colleagues at the
federal reserve but what i will
say is that i think it is critical that
the us dollar
remain the world's reserve currency uh
certainly it should remain the world's
reserve currency
based on the fundamental impact of the
dollar and i would hate to see a
situation
where people are no longer using the us
dollar not because there's been major
macroeconomic changes but rather that
the us
has fallen behind in technology so i
know the federal reserve and other
other central banks around the world are
having discussions about
central bank digital currencies and and
to some extent there's kind of a
metaphysical question as to
well should it actually be a digital
currency on a blockchain
or can we simply speed up our payment
systems but the bottom line
is that i think everyone agrees that our
payment mechanisms in the united states
and in many countries around the world
uh are have not kept pace with
technology
and so i think we definitely want to put
a lot of thought and emphasis
into the debate the discussion and
regardless if we go to an
actual central bank digital currency or
we just go to a more sophisticated
payment system
i agree that something has to be done
yeah that's a really interesting
perspective of kind of balancing
is it actually going to be a digital
currency backed by central bank or just
faster payments
um obviously i think from the crypto
community perspective
uh they think government is really
really slow and bureaucratic and kind of
very intentional with
the way that they move um if you then
asked if somebody in the government or a
large corporation they'd be like oh my
god crypto moves you know at light speed
uh and so there's almost this inherent
tension between uh
kind of not messing things up you know
when you're working with the government
or kind of making decisions that affect
entire economies and
populations and in the crypto world i
think there's kind of this iterative
technology driven
how do we just kind of experiment and
innovate as fast as we can
how do you and your organization kind of
one stay up to date just on
kind of the fast-moving crypto world and
really understand like here's what's
happening
and then also any systems or processes
you guys have built in terms of
being able to just kind of synthesize
all the information so you you make sure
that you've got
everything you need to actually make the
decisions that you guys look to make on
kind of a quarterly or annual basis
yeah so first of all i would be the
first to agree with you
that if innovation is is unlikely to
come from the government
can government be innovators yes but in
an area like blockchain
an area that is really focused on
algorithms on mathematics
on on on continuing to develop
technology and ideas
just as america just as it's always been
in our country
i think the private sector is is the
ultimate generator of great types of
innovation and so i want to continue to
do that and so i see my role
as a regulator is not so much innovating
ourselves but we want to be innovative
for a regulator
but not necessarily innovate for the
community but we've got to keep up
the good news is that the cftc when i
came into the organization
it was clear we were at a crossroads all
of this new technology was coming to the
forefront we were putting the financial
crisis and the dodd-frank
reforms behind us and it was a good
opportunity for us to revisit our
mission
so we came up with a new mission
statement and the entire agency voted on
it
uh everyone in our regional offices and
it's to promote
the integrity resilience and vibrancy
of u.s derivatives markets through sound
regulation
now all of those characteristics are
important integrity resilience and
vibrancy we'll talk about those probably
a little later
but of those vibrancy is the one that
gets at the innovation
gets at the innovation point that we
don't want our markets to be stale
we want them to be continuing to develop
and and
be innovative we also chose our our four
core values and among them
is forward thinking that we always want
to stay ahead of the curve
so then becomes the question well how do
you do that particularly how do you do
that in a federal government agency
that is required by law to come up with
a five-year plan
uh almost like the soviet union right
and so we do have a very different
culture than silicon valley
um i think the a couple of keys to that
number one is education education
education and so
we've created uh lab cftc a few years
ago when i came in we actually elevated
lab cftc
our innovation arm to report directly to
the chairman
and it is essentially a liaison between
the regulator and those that are be
regulated as well as those of developing
new technologies in silicon valley
elsewhere in california and all over the
world and so
we want to learn as much as we can and
we want to listen
to the right to the blockchain community
and at the same time we hope
the blockchain community would listen to
us to learn a little bit about our
regulatory framework
so there truly is a meeting of the minds
but in terms of education
uh just during the pandemic our lab cftc
has held something like 60 different
courses
and i myself have had have taken
tutorials
so for a series of six to eight weeks
every wednesday and thursday night
i would sit down and i have a course on
various types of
of technologies i'd learn the the you
know the shaw 256 how the algorithm
works really get into the details
because i feel like look
at the end of the day this is under my
purview and i owe it to
to the blockchain community to at least
understand it to a level that i can make
informed policy decisions
and then the final thing i would say is
in washington
there's a mantra personnel is policy it
all comes down to the people in many
cases
so we've looked and i've tried to hire
people
that come from the tech community so our
new head of lab cftc
she came from a silicon valley based
company two
one person in my office as well as one
of our division directors
came from a cryptocurrency exchange uh
and then finally we just hired one of
the few phd
ivy league economists in the world with
a background in crypto
so it's really important that we have
those people in the agency
and so while one we're never going to
have the kind of innovative culture that
that a
silicon valley based firm has for
example we can at least have people that
are familiar with the technology
that want to learn and they're willing
to take risk
yeah and in the lab cftc i think is is a
great example where
um kind of as a regulatory body and a
government organization
you know understanding where can we play
and kind of help to encourage innovation
and experimentation but also at the same
time
really empower the teams i think to
understand here's
what you should be thinking about here's
what you should not be and kind of
here's the boundaries to play with and i
think is
obviously just in the success of that
initiative uh pretty obvious there
um previously you've talked about uh
kind of the demand
for bitcoin futures or other types of
derivatives and
um you know i think the way that you've
talked about it is bitcoin futures
demand has been
lower than other commodity type uh
futures
um mechanisms maybe talk a little bit
about you know
why do you think that is is that
something that is just the nature of
it's small and it takes time to kind of
build up demand
and then how the cftc sees their role
you know is your job to help encourage
and grow the demand
is it to just simply make sure that
people are doing the right things like
how do you
um think about the demand and kind of
the day-to-day responsibilities that you
guys have
yeah so i'll take the last part of the
question first which is what is what is
our role in this and so we don't pick
winners and losers
our job is to create a structure whereby
derivatives can be traded
in a market that allows for price
discovery and for
hedging purposes and and and it goes
back really to those three things that i
mentioned
integrity resilience and vibrant
vibrancy and i would put a premium on
the first one that's why we put it first
integrity
so if if users around the country and
throughout the world come to one of our
markets
they know that the bid and offers are
good they know that they represent
actual supply and demand in the market
and there's no fraud going on there's no
pumping and dumping that's all this kind
of stuff that we look out for
and so our job is to sort of be the the
umpire
to create the the the ballpark but but
allow the various products to go
and to succeed based on their own merit
so
getting back to the question well
volumes are down so
one of the things you mentioned is
exactly right
derivatives actually started trading in
the united states i think back in 1848
or something right
and so many of the contracts that we
even have today things like
oil futures and other contracts the
contracts themselves have been
virtually the same in some cases for 30
years so there's a tremendous amount of
just
length of time that they've been trading
and demand obviously didn't start the
trading volumes didn't start at uh
at what they are today they obviously
started and evolved since then
the other aspect though that so so time
will tell i think and so i do expect the
volumes to grow
in the years ahead but the other aspect
of it has to do
with the industry itself as i mentioned
before
really our derivatives markets serve two
purposes
first they allow hedging and then they
also create
price discovery where people can rely in
some cases on div
derivatives prices to inform their
decisions in the actual
underlying markets right now
um if there's a real question as to who
will
actually purchase ether or bitcoin
contracts for purposes of hedging
right now the only people that we're
seeing in these markets are speculators
meaning
they actually don't have an underlying
risk that they're trying to lay off
they're just
they're just investing in in bitcoin
effectively or ether
just as they would be if they were
buying it on the cash exchange
now there are people like miners for
example who are naturally short bitcoin
for example
in other words they know they're going
to get bitcoin at a certain amount
uh so they may hedge their position now
so they can guarantee
ultimately what that price would be in
u.s dollars or some other currency
but we're not seeing at this point a
underlying market
for long people that would be long in
bitcoin in the futures markets
now that could all change the to the
extent that we start to see bitcoin
ether and other digital currencies being
used for commerce
so i think that's going to be the key
it's going to be the length of time but
also the extent to which digital assets
and cryptocurrencies
begin begin being used by the real
economy and there's people that say
i need to go to the futures market to
hedge it the other thing we're seeing of
course is right now the price discovery
is really in the cash exchanges
people are not looking to the futures
markets for actual prices
but that could change in time as well
but but that's the lay of the land at
present
got it and so one of the things that um
there is a lot of demand for right now
is kind of this defy or decentralized
mechanisms platforms products etc
talk a little bit about these
decentralized exchanges i think that the
kind of bitcoin and crypto community
sees them as a natural kind of end state
right and that's where they want to kind
of evolve to
obviously from a regulation standpoint
it becomes much harder to
uh regulate something that doesn't have
somebody behind it or ownership and so
how do you guys see kind of the current
state of decentralized exchanges and
then how does the regulatory environment
either evolve or kind of work with
something that ends up looking very
different than the centralized exchanges
that we have today in the traditional
markets
right well first of all i will say that
i find it all very fascinating
and so the the idea of defy and the
ability to to sort of essentially create
not only uh address the trust
the trust issue which i think some of
the the
the first generation uh cryptocurrencies
have dealt with but then taking it a
step farther and actually having an
autonomous system
that runs the entire thing is is is very
fascinating
and of course it arguably takes away
human error so there are a number of
potential benefits to that
the questions that we would have to ask
is that over a long period of time the
commodity exchange act itself that
created our derivatives exchanges
uh was was first passed in 1936
and it's been changed you know continue
to evolve ever since then and so
when we look at an exchange we have to
make sure that it meets a number of our
core principles
core principles that are there to ensure
the integrity of resilience and also
allow for the vibrancy
and so integrity is an important one for
example we want to make
sure that there's no glitches no bugs uh
uh you know there's there's no way to
sort of do a
51 attack or something like that or
other sorts of things that
even come into play in the defy space
there's the question of
anti-money laundering of people being
able to get on the system
so all of those things we'd have to
think about resilience the second
attribute i mentioned
we normally do system safeguard exams
on our clearinghouses on our exchanges
and so we would want to know that's the
case there as well
and then we'd also have to think about
the financial side because for every
exchange
there's also a clearinghouse there's a
way that that payments are facilitated
so we would have to think long and hard
about that as well
so i think it's something that we would
continue to study
and as it evolves my hope would be that
our agency
our statute and our regulations would
evolve with it
got it and so as you kind of look at um
a lot of this evolution i think there's
uh a lot of
regulatory bodies um individuals and
also from the crypto community just
various
ideas that continue to kind of um you
know surface and some of those ideas
are around for very short periods of
time somebody kind of critiques them and
says maybe that's not the greatest idea
whether it's a product to build a
regulation to put forward
but some of them do have legs to them
and one of the most recent pieces of
legislation is called the digital
commodity exchange act of 2020
and the idea here is to basically create
a new type of
regulatory governing body talk a little
bit about this piece of legislation and
although maybe it isn't yet here this is
what we're going to do
it does have some pretty interesting
ideas um along with just being recent
in terms of being put forward yeah well
when i talk to
the blockchain community and the crypto
community
there are two things that i think i
always hear um
number one there's a lack of clarity
there's a lack of clarity as to how
these things should be regulated
and the first threshold is is it a
security or is it a commodity
very different uh they're they're sort
two diversion paths in the road one
leads to the sec and a very different
type of regulation
the other if it's a commodity leads into
airspace which is a more
principles-based approach and i think
in in some cases is favored by many
people in the crypto community
um so that's one thing and so we need
clarity at some point we need a lot more
clarity so people as they're designing
products as they're experimenting with
products can really kind of understand
how they will be regulated in the end
because it could very well affect the
value as well
as as how how it performs and how it's
set up
the second big issue i hear is that
because there's some
there's there's the uncertainty
overlaying that
is the fact that there's complete
fragmentation
where there are 50 states so if you're a
cryptocurrency exchange now
you have to deal with every single
jurisdiction not only in the united
states but abroad but certainly in the
us
where where you you must have to
register there are requirements
and so the founding fathers going way
back
talking about innovation well i think
1787 was a great year for innovation
because it was the year of our
constitution
but one of the things the founding
fathers i think got right is
federalism and the idea that if
something is in interstate commerce it
should be
regulated federally so we could have a
national economy
and then other things were left to the
states well i can't think of anything
more emblematic
of interstate commerce than blockchain
and so
if you if we're able to have a single
federal regulatory regime
that will create what's called
preemption also in the constitution
which basically allows federal law to be
supreme
but you have one law to apply to comply
with and therefore you don't have to
worry about the patchwork of 50
different states and so
it may very well be that for some areas
certain consumer protections it makes
sense to have the states involved and
the states play an important role
but for other aspects it may make far
more sense to have a single federal
regime
that will allow innovation provide
clarity and then also
allow this to to grow in a way that it
can in other countries because they
don't have the fragmentation
yeah that's really really fascinating
way to look at it um i know that for
myself
uh the team at la blockchain summit and
just people around the bitcoin and
crypto community uh they don't really
feel um or they don't get the
opportunity to talk to you very often
right
and it's because you've got a lot of
other things going on um
if you had the chance to kind of sit
down with each person
individually with kind of one resounding
message
what would that like call to action um
or that message be
you know you lead one of the most
important organizations and probably the
most forward thinking in terms of this
stuff
just is there one kind of single message
that people can take away and and kind
of hear directly from you that you think
would be important
i would say our door is open our door is
open
come see us come visit with us i think
you'll find
uh for a federal agency we are eager to
learn
and we want to make a difference and and
and and we want to be
we want to provide sound regulation as i
mentioned but we also understand that
innovation
uh also necessitates some flexibility
and so
so we are our door is open we're always
listening
and we're always experimenting and our
goal is to ensure that our derivatives
markets again
have the integrity have the resilience
but are also vibrant
that's awesome and amazing to hear
because i think
you uh you will get plenty of people
knocking on that door now now that uh
they've heard that message
uh chairman tarbert thank you so much
for taking the time to do this i know
that people are really excited to hear
from you
and i hope people learn something today
so thanks so much for your time my
pleasure
and thanks again la blockchain summit is
is amazing
and i'm honored to be here